the One Piece manga just showed us that
Shanks might be the strongest pirate in
the world and this incredibly hype
moment has me feeling like we're truly
close to finding the one piece just a
couple of chapters ago we saw Shanks
about to confront used as kid outside of
elbaf and in this chapter not only does
shenzu win the fight he demonstrates his
unbelievable Power by completely
obliterating hit and taking his most
pressed possession the road ponigle of
rubbings that he had with him and this
has huge implications for the race to
find the one piece as we'll discuss in
just a second we also learned that
someone from the Blackbeard crew May
soon be making their appearance on
Egghead Island which has even more chaos
to this Arc that is shaping up to be an
all-out war and honestly just looking at
Chang's or even Blackbeard you have to
admit that they both have just
ridiculous drip I mean just look at
Blackbeard's rings and his necklace and
you might have noticed that I'm actually
wearing a watch for a change now even
though I haven't worn a watch in ages
honestly this has now changed thanks to
today's super unique sponsor altskin hot
scan is actually one of the coolest
companies that I've had the pleasure
working with on this channel and not
just because they're an austria-based
company super close to where I'm
actually from and they make these
incredibly unique looking high-end
watches and jewelry huskan actually
means wood core in German so it's no
surprise that the company Works
incredibly nature oriented and that many
of their products including the things
that they so generously send me here
include an incredibly looking
combination of wood Stone and metal
elements I personally ended up picking
this set because it goes quite well with
my dark wood slash matte black theme
that of going on as you can see and this
watch here is just a true piece of art
and so satisfying to wear and look at
and they even sent me some beautiful
things for the Fantastic women in my
life and you can now use my exclusive
code O'Hara 15 for 15 of store-wide to
to get a little bit of that shank strip
going for yourself as well and now back
to the video and of course we're
starting off with the Blackbeard Pirates
because we see only a small corner of
one of his ships but we do get a clear
image of his Infamous three skull Jolly
Roger this could of course mean that
Blackbeard himself is coming or it could
be another one off his Titanic captain
so let's explore who we think it might
be and why they might be coming to akkit
islands in the first place all the way
back in chapter 1063 we saw Blackbeard
fighting against law on some random
Island and he had almost half of his
Titanic captains with him they were daku
and his horse stronger Jesus Burgess and
vanagar so it's possible that
Blackbeard's already defeated law and is
now coming full force to echis now we
also have to ask ourselves if this would
actually make sense as we'll discuss in
full detail later on Shanks was able to
easily defeat kit and we just saw in
wano that kid and law are roughly
comparable in strength since they work
together to feed big mom now to be fair
we do know that law is more strategic
and careful than kids but if we think
that Blackbeard is actually close to
Shanks and strength and close to Luffy
then it is definitely reasonable to
think that Blackbeard could take down
law here if this is true it can lead to
some truly mind-blowing outcomes because
we know Blackbeard is still hunting
devil fruits for example in chapter 1059
he tried to kill Boa Hancock and take
her devil fruit and so if he actually
did defeat law just imagine what the
Blackbeard Pirates would be able to do
with lost devil fruits immortality
surgery anyone but of course that
outcome isn't certain Aslam might be
able to teleport himself away using his
devil fruit or even if they did get lost
fruit it would definitely take someone
sometime at least to learn how to
properly use it so it is possible that
Blackbeard is coming to echid Island if
this battle is over if it is Blackbeard
then Egghead island is about to get even
more chaotic than it already is however
it could also be some of the other
Titanic captains such as Vasco shots
Katarina Devon Alvaro Pizarro San Juan
wolf or Lafitte or of course the most
interesting option in my opinion the
former Marine Admiral aokiji now while
aokiji isn't confirmed to be a Titanic
captain he makes the most sense out of
any of them to make an appearance at
eckat Islands we still don't have an
explanation for why he joined this
Cutthroat crew after leaving the Marines
but with all of the world government and
Marine forces coming to Egghead it would
make sense for him to make his
reappearance here once again I mean just
imagine how kiji confronting kizaru in
an epic battle between light and ice or
he could even come after sansatter and
who is also coming to eckat Island one
of the gorosei now aside from aokiji's
past connections with the world
government we have to ask why do the
Blackbeard Pirates want to come in the
first place remember that Blackbeard
thrives when he is able to take
advantage of chaos he broke into imple
down after the wild Prison Break he took
whitebeard's devil fruit when the former
strongest man was basically already dead
so it would make sense that Blackbeard
would use the fighting on econ Islands
to swoop in and take whatever he wants
what does he wants well he could want
another powerful devil fruit maybe
Luffy's kizarus or someone else like
Lucy's leopard fruit or maybe just like
Shanks Blackbeard could be gathering the
pony glyphs as he prepares to find the
one piece and as you know right now
there are three rubbings of the pony
glyphs lying unprotected on board of the
straw hat ship remember that the sunny
was taken up into the Dome on top of
eckat Island so it isn't completely
abandoned but there isn't anyone
watching the ship right now now that
Zoro and Brooke have joined the fighting
as well and alongside the pornograph's
Blackbeard could be after someone who
can read these ancient writings as well
we've already talked about the
importance of having someone who can
read them before on this channel but a
lot has changed since the end of wano
funnily enough currently we only have
confirmed that Robin and this guy from
wano cannot actually read the pony
glyphs however there are two other
possible candidates here first is big
man's daughter pudding who has already
been captured by the Blackbeard Pirates
because we know that pudding is a
Half-Blood member of the three-eye tribe
which means that she has the ability to
awaken the voice of all things this
power should let her understand the pony
glyphs but she hasn't awakened it quite
yet as far as we know at least and the
other candidate is of course the genius
scientist Dr vegapunk himself because in
chapter 1066 we're being told that
vegapunk memorized everything that the
scholars from the island of O'Hara had
ever discovered and so if this is true
vegapunk should be able to read the pony
glyphs although this was never confirmed
officially in the story so far but if he
can read them then it's possible that
his satellites like Shaka Pythagoras
Lilith and Edison could as well since
they all sync up with the punk records
on a daily basis and if that is true the
number of people who could possibly
translate the pony lives just suddenly
jumps up to an insane amount of 10. and
another crazy option is of course if
Punk records were the Vega punks
download their daily experiences could
create some Google translate like
program that could interpret the pony
glyphs on its own could you imagine if
this knowledge was shared with the
entire world what if all the secrets
that have been lost for 800 years became
easily accessible for everyone to read
the world government would lose their
minds and it would completely change one
piece forever so things are definitely
heating up and yet all that crazy
speculation about Blackbeard and the one
piece and everything else can't live up
to the Glorious figure of red hair
Shanks in the second half of this
chapter and uh I don't know about all of
you but with all of this talk of pony
glyphs it truly feels like we're getting
so close to finding the one piece right
now so keep watching And subscribe to
the channel as we get to the most
exciting part of this chapter because
there is so much that we learned about
shanks's power in this section but
equally important is what we learn about
Chang's true character from his
interactions with his fleets
specifically we learned that the Allied
captains who are in shanks's Fleet are
actually pretty pathetic we have this
older guy with Dentures another who's
captain of the puddle Pirates and the
third one called panicky pururu even kid
himself comments that shanks's Fleet
seems to be a bit of a joke and we're
told that all of these Pirates have only
survived so far because Shanks has kept
them safe under his banner and after
we've all been questioning this heavily
for a while all of this really supports
the idea that Changs is after all a good
guy despite some recent hints that he
could have a darker side as well however
much like Whitebeard Ching seems to look
out for those who need protection and he
is fiercely loyal to his friends which
becomes really obvious in this chapter
which now of course takes us to the
actual main battle where we see shanks's
true power on full display and first of
all we get a glimpse of his future side
abilities which seem to let him seem way
further into the future than we
previously thought possible back when
future site was first introduced we're
being told that even a master like big
mom's strongest son karakari could only
see a few seconds into the future Max
but in this scene Shang seems to see
quite a bit further than that as he sees
kids entire attack about to destroy his
Fleet ships with his magnetic railgun
and it's at this point where friendly
kind-hearted Shanks kind of flips the
switch finally for the very first time
ever because with his Fleet in danger he
leaps across the water and delivers a
massive sword slash that knocks out both
Captain Kidd and his Vice Captain killer
and on top of that shanks's conquer
hockey also knocks out many of the
weaker pirates on the ship as well this
is a truly legendary Display of Power
both in terms of the story and for power
scaling first of all shanks's ruthless
side mirrors exactly what we saw in the
very first chapter of One Piece because
right at the start of the story remember
that Chang's didn't want to fight
against those Mountain Bandits when they
came looking for trouble inside the bar
however the moment that the bandits
kidnapped Luffy Shanks was ready to kill
every last one of them and the exact
same is true in this chapter as well
where Shang shifts from joking with his
Fleet to wiping out the kids pirates in
a matter of seconds and the attack that
Shanks uses here Divine departure is
also the very same attack that Raja used
to repel the samurai Odin in chapter 966
and this shows us that Changs truly is
the pupil of the former pirate king
galdi Roger and seems to have reached
his same level of strength at least but
even more than that this feat also gives
us insight into the hierarchy of the
pirate's strength and yeah that's right
we're gonna do some power scaling here
you see even even though kitten law took
down big mom and juano together neither
of those two could stand up to a yonko
and survive for long on their own
however both kid and law each did damage
to the both yonkos which is impressive
in its own right however shank seems to
still be a step even above big mom and
kaido as he destroys both kit and killer
with a single attack and this is a big
reveal in terms of understanding Luffy's
strength as well clearly Luffy was
portrayed as stronger than Kitten Lost
since he ultimately took down kaido all
by himself however I'm really not sure
how that compares to what we've just
seen Shanks do to kids could Luffy take
out kitten killer with a single blow but
I don't know but this scene may have
just shown us that Luffy still has quite
some growing left to do but besides
Shanks we also get to see the true power
of the Giants here Dorian bragi who
unleash a combined attack that destroys
kid's ship sending kid killer and the
rest of the crew to drown in the ocean
to a apparently die is still still one
piece that we're reading but surely they
aren't just going to drown here right is
there someone in the water that can save
them or will Shanks show Mercy or could
Oda finally be taking the gloves off as
we head into the final war and just
start killing people either way Shanks
and the Giants are not messing around
when it comes to elbaf or finding the
one piece which we'll discuss about more
in just a second because first another
fascinating reveal is that Shanks is
keeping Taps on Blackbeard's whereabouts
because in this panel here we can see
that he's told by the crew's doctor
Hangul that Blackbeard has just left
Pirate Island which is Blackbeard's home
base and Shanks also comments that he
was sure that Blackbeard would have gone
to wano so we have to ask ourselves how
is Shang staying informed of
Blackbeard's movements all the time does
he have some sort of spy within the
Blackbeard Pirates possibly aokiji or is
it someone else or is he just having
someone sneaking behind Blackbeard all
the time and even more importantly why
was he so sure that Blackbeard would go
to wano did he expect Blackbeard to go
after the pony glyph there or perhaps to
try to take kaido's devil fruit was that
why he was in wano in the first place
whatever the answer is it seems like Oda
is really preparing us for an epic
confrontation between both Shanks and
blackbeards but if Blackbeard is heading
to eckhead Island right now that could
mean that Shanks will go as well also
remember that GARP is hunting Blackbeard
to rescue Kobe so GARP could be coming
to Echo too truly it seems like the
boxes are all being checked off for
eckhead becoming Marine Forge 2.0 and if
this is going to be a huge Turning Point
like Marine for it it will likely kick
off the final stretch to find the one
piece so it is time to look where the
main players stand in terms of finding
love tale first and we kind of got an
update on this after wano hit law and
Luffy all got a rubbing of the road Pony
glyph from one of course so plus one for
all of them law and Luffy have the one
from Zoe but we aren't sure if they gave
that one to kids Luffy definitely had
the one from whole cake Island and we
were told that kid got a copy of that
one from someone as well so Luffy
definitely has three law and kid have
either two or three depending on what
was exactly shared between the three
Rivals after wano and we actually do get
a hint about that in this chapter
because as kids crew begs for shanks's
mercy and to spare their Captain we get
this panel right here showing them
handing over kids rubbing off his road
pornographs and if you ask me it looks a
lot like this is three rubbings might be
two but if this is actually the three
from Zoe whole kick Island and wano that
certainly changes the entire course of
the entire story here's why most people
expect the fourth Road Pony glyph to be
on elbaf which is where we all thought
Luffy would go next after wano if it is
then Shanks will definitely have a
rubbing of it since this is shanks's
territory and this is probably the
reason he came to elbeth in the first
place so if we count the album poniglyph
plus the two or maybe three that he
stole from the kid pirates that means
that Shanks also has three or maybe even
all four Road Pony glyphs in his
possession right now if it's only three
then he just needs the one from Zoe if
it is all four then this is a huge
historic moment in the history of One
Piece because this panel right here
could be the very first time that
someone besides Roger has possibly
collected all four Road Pony glyphs and
could be ready to find love tale as long
as they can read the rubbings which as
we discussed earlier could certainly be
a lot easier than it was before thanks
to eckhit Island and vegapung's research
however there is still a lot of unknowns
here Shanks could have as few as two
Road Pony glyphs or up to four of them
and that leaves us with blackbeards if
he defeated law and took his rubbings
then he would have the one ones from Zoe
wano and possibly whole cake Island
that's if kid actually shared it with
law which not so sure about that but
even if law didn't have all three
Blackbeard might be able to steal the
third one from the Thousand Sunny on
Eckhart Island right now and so this all
means that there is an entirely possible
scenario that all three of these
contenders Blackbeard Shanks and Luffy
are left with one more rubbing to
collect unless shang's already has them
all and with all of these long-running
threats coming together slowly we're
finally starting to get a clearer
picture towards what this final race to
find the one piece will actually look
like after a kid Island there are still
so many different things that can still
happen I mean if both Blackbeard and
Shanks come to Egghead one of them could
leave Victorious and be ready to find
love tale or if Shanks doesn't come then
Luffy is very likely heading to elbav
Next where we think the fourth Road Pony
glyph is located and Blackbeard will be
hunting for the final Pony glyph as well
so it seems that Shanks is the true
wildcard of the story right now is he
actually a contender to find the one
piece and become pirate king is he just
clearing the way for Luffy or does he
have other plans that we have yet to
fully see well if you want to know the
full story of Shanks and all the
possibilities for his future you can
watch this video right here thanks so
much for watching and also once again
thanks to Holtz Karen for sponsoring
this video check their Link in the
description below